foreign
wasn't aware of him
theovan found out live when he was on
Portnoy show watch this
hey we're doing rough and rowdy which
you're doing the the stream with right I
think so
I've seen your face in the flyer
so he's probably doing it I don't know
he gave me thinking about it oh he's
like oh the number's not right what's
going on are you doing the stream no I
don't know I didn't make that deal I
don't know
Brandon Brandon made the deal
I just got put on the flyer I guess
um
I don't know it looked I saw it's shab
it's your face who are the other two
faces on that flyer do you know the
flyer I'm talking about it's Joey Diaz
but he got replaced
is
Theo's face still on the flyer yeah
plastered all over the fire
well I mean it's I I don't know I don't
know a lot about this I will look into
it though I appreciate it
that's angry Theo that's that's not as
angry as you're gonna get him
appreciate it we didn't it wasn't
through us
oh well it wasn't through me that's what
I'm saying
we've both been we're being trafficked
bro I don't know how this is happening
son so do I have you see we're being sex
trafficked yes I love Theo Theo's
[ __ ] hilarious yeah permission to
just put your face on any okay hold on
the back hold on
[Music]
I don't know how this is happening son
so do I have your permission to just put
your face on any flyer than I want yeah
look I'll take the Pug but I didn't do
it uh now rough and rowdy and that's
where you guys just get just and these
are just Amazon drivers and stuff and
what they just beat each other before we
continue if you guys can do me a huge
favor hit no no Fox
Robbie Foxx announce it and then
um we're doing you you
are doing a side stream with it so if
when you can watch it and then you
announce it or comment kind of like the
Manning cast you know for ESPN yeah so
you Shob all those guys it's gonna be
great are you doing a live stream of it
too where are the announcers for the
actual event which people will be able
to watch live yeah they stream it and
you're gonna watch it live Theo and
people can see you commenting on it but
how do they get it why how would they
watch two things at one time Theo a lot
of people simulcast man it's it's pretty
popular actually a lot of people like
putting on a fight dude to talk about a
live fight while it's going on it's
actually it's a lot of people do it you
know
I think what they would do if they were
interested in you is they buy your
stream and ours turn the volume down on
ours watch it but listen to you oh dang
yeah yeah wow and now keep in mind that
it's giving up
um
shut up
and it breaks my heart to say this but
don't worry I'm making it up to you guys
Joey Diaz cannot leave New Jersey his
book is dropping and he messed up his
schedule so he can't come out to LA on
that Friday and make it happen so I
called up another big dog going all
right Joey I'll figure it out and we
have Donald cowboy Cerrone filling in
for the great Joey go go Diaz you got
Donald Cerrone one of the very best ever
great does he know because Theo didn't
seem to know
so did Donald know he's going to be
doing this these guys know it's that UFC
Octagon his WC days he's a living legend
and he is filling in so you have Donald
Cerrone Rampage Jackson Theo Von and my
thick ass
your face looks terrible and also feel
Von again as we just saw earlier has no
idea he's did you book somebody again
did you just book somebody and didn't
tell them
or is this worse or let's go a little
crazy let's go to Wild are we blaming
big gay lion I think that big gay lion
I think that big gay lion probably made
some promises
and Brendan is to the point now where he
doesn't even talk to Theo he it all goes
through the big gay lion
the big gay translator
and I believe that that's where the mix
have happened Friday at 5 PM live my
theory Sure okay so he went to sleep
right he went to sleep like a week ago
and he met this Indian in the desert
it's a big gay Indian in the desert no
that's the plot of Wayne's World too if
you booked him
if you book them they will come
and who's that that's a weird naked
Indian
[ __ ] stupid dude and who's that old
who's that old lady that's my old lady
lady so we're gonna get Rip Taylor at
this show too yes
and and we're gonna get Aerosmith
at an old man fashioning kayak out of a
log
[Laughter]
I mean Pearl Jam and then Saturday you
have UFC 2 82 the big boy pay-per-view
in Las Vegas and your main event is
Patty pimlet that's a people's Main
Event let's be real versus Jared Gordon
and then you have Jan blockovich and now
this is where things get very
interesting because the clip I'm about
to show you is from a Tim Dylan look
Phil Vaughn's podcast I'm like sure I'll
do it I showed up to the theater podcast
it just wasn't his podcast so it came on
I was like where's Theo they're like
well he's on here it's like that's weird
but it was a totally different podcast
so I didn't care I was just confused
right no it's funny because I just saw
Brandon's child was lying because
Brendan lies a lot so I saw Brandon made
something up because Brandon's like oh
yeah Portland Oregon it's gonna be great
I'm like he knows it's us he goes yeah
he's really excited about it so he's
just making things up so that's all I
was talking about on my show is how
hilarious because you were like what the
[ __ ] is going on you're like why am I
talking to these basically Brenda shop
told so Brandon shop at this point now
they're not even hiding how stupid he is
no yeah British shop just lies he just
makes stuff up
all right let's see if we're getting
donations here yeah they're not covering
for his ass anymore
no
I think that the Rogan protection fell
off with the protection spell ran out